have you ever thought what if someone's
gonna make a movie about Jake Gyllenhaal
who would play Jake Gyllenhaal have you
ever thought about it no yeah because
I'm available awesome yeah that would be
real convincing yeah actually I have
thought about it
what was what's happening I'm waiting on
it thought about and it's a little weird
okay because I'm sitting right next to
him yes always a nervous whenever come
on on the show because I've been like
writing it for a long time and I said
yeah I don't know what it is yeah yeah
well yeah I mean we're pretty similar
probably like it's like looking into a
mirror
[Laughter]
his voice come out of your face I got I
got Monday through Thursday mornings
open and then Friday pretty much wide
open yeah you know let's start it I
gotta be here by like 1:30 yeah we'll
shoot nights
is there a famous person that people
always say you look like I mean
sometimes people say that I look like
Aaron Rodgers oh yes I can see that yeah
yeah I think we have I think we have do
we have anything yeah you guys there's a
similarity there that's pretty close
there are times when I've been watching
the game and I'm like Jake Gyllenhaal is
good
I really do I do feel like I do feel
like you know I am I mean you could
probably play me because I am pretty
athletic I don't mean though I shouldn't
have laughed there I did but I was
getting you back earlier for calling my
show a toilet but what but but acing
toilet yeah a really good you know what
really fancy this show is and I was in a
line toilet thank you yeah
you